I want to talk with the episode the
aired I guess two weeks ago I guess we
can talk about it now it's not a spoiler
anymore but senior MacGyver no like very
very emotional app still like what was
that like for you shooting that episode
sometimes you get lucky with stuff you
go to try and you just can't you can't
bring it and sometimes you get lucky
where you just can't help but cry in the
scene and that was definitely one of
those ones so lucky for me because the
director of shot it for about four hours
Oh sometimes I like make sure that they
have a couple tags you get it right to
move on David kept wanting to shoot so
but then he got some great stuff so that
was was it that was a really great
episode I mean we're surprised that they
killed him off or was that a plan for a
while um I had my suspicions
because generally what happens in a
story like you know think about Luke
Skywalker Luke Skywalker's The Fool the
hero comes learn something by the end
but he needs someone to die which is
obi-wan Kenobi and this was the mentor
and also you know I can I can see the
signs leading up to it I mean again
cancer so what better way to go out and
to actually help save the Sun and that's
what he did right I know a lot of fans
are talking about that this really seems
like a more vulnerable McIver this
season have you found that was that a
real choice that you guys made to really
develop the character um yeah yeah I
think it absolutely was it was a
definitely some conversation that I had
with tearing the talus who was like you
know like this to see you just more
vulnerable but and and he really liked
and pushed me because I did have like
this is exhausting I have to do it like
it's great though he was right it's good
and it really it only gets better yeah
like at this point obviously it's
amazing that the show has been on for
four seasons but do you find at this
point you have to find those things to
keep it interesting or keep developing
the character so it doesn't get stale I
think so I think that's true any any
ever as some audiences don't mind
consistency in some ways but you always
have to spice it up with that
and they did a really good job this year
so many different things to the episode
that air is tomorrow I don't know when
this commute is but the one that airs
tomorrow is crazy I mean we've never
done over that it's really good so nice
to see what people think yeah so if you
can't remember like what the next three
episodes are what can you tease people
is gonna happen for this next like
section of the season that they are
gonna see well you're gonna see lots of
it without ruining anything friction
between all the characters things are
going to cuz you used to seeing the
characters sort of then we have a
mission it's one episode start finish of
a story and we go in and save the day
and come home everything's good and that
it's not necessarily the case with
what's gonna happen as you've seen with
these episodes and what's going to
happen getting closer to the end and
yeah it's really good we've like I said
well the next episode there's again
without ruining anything dreamlike
sequences with people 120 in the like
clappers from the 20s and all kinds of
stuff in max mind there's a dark Mac
which is an alter-ego which is about oh
yeah exactly so like I say all kinds of
stuff we've never done before it's gonna
be really really cool yeah so it seems
like what you said before like you have
no idea what's gonna happen this winter
it's like when you'll be back to work or
any kind of plan at this point no I
think I think we're with the rest of the
world right now we have no idea once
once everything seems to be safe as you
know when you work on a crew like that
on a set like that we're working with
people in such close proximity all the
time that I mean we're definitely one of
those people it's not like we can social
distance at work it's impossible are you
feeling that void a little bit of not
being around people like now they're at
like the month Mark II feeling that yes
of course the truth of the matter is yes
are there things but I keep I let him
get to me I think it was two weeks I was
good the third week was really rough
now we do the point where they're
starting to accept but that's my reality
for now and this may never happen for
the rest of our lives or if it does well
then we're gonna keep doing it so we
better get used to it but if it never
happens to the rest of your life I want
to think about the times where I was
able to play video games guilt-free I
was able to work out and and not worry
about any of these other things making
most of that time involved yeah
now one thing that is definitely
happening no matter where we are like
that you got a big birthday coming up in
August right yeah how you feel how you
feel about it does that feel like a
weird birthday like kidding 30 is that
are you waiting to be considered an
adult my entire life so people probably
for me I am so excited I just want to
drop everything that happened before 26
would that be nice yeah but season four
like what we've seen a MacGyver in these
next few episodes like how would you
define season four season four is
hardcore season four is it's it's it's
just it's the TV show not saying
anything about the prior seasons but
this is the TV show that I wanted to
make since day one and be a part of and
we we have fully achieved it more than I
imagined when we finally got there any
it's a really nice feeling and I could
be more specific but it's really hard to
talk about these next episodes without
ruining them and and but as you saw with
the episode with James MacGyver passing
away well he didn't pass away he steamed
was a hero in that moment but yeah he it
starts with that and then it just keeps
on going
and uh yeah that's interesting you say
that in terms of like it's the show you
wanted to make now like obviously when
you started this show you know people
know that says like reboot of a very
famous show was that yeah kind of an
issue starting out because you have to
please the fans of that original show
before you really have your own identity
yeah I mean and it's so interesting
when you say please the fans there's all
these conversations about who to please
and they the people making decisions
don't how could they possibly know who
to please and how to please them so it's
still an opinion and then the you know
sort of those opinions get justified
over time and and and we it was it was
certainly I tried to just put it out of
my mind because of course they're gonna
compare me to Richard Dean Anderson the
whole time there's honestly nothing I
can do about that
I mean I'm on the show I'm a 10 years
younger than he was when he started so
it's not even accurate comparison in my
thinking but but we we made it this far
and and everybody's very proud of that